There's one last thing I want to
demonstrate with operators and
that's how the increment and
decrement operators affect assignment.
We'll start by creating
a few variables and
we'll also create a variable
that adds all of these together.
So right now our total
pounds is equal to four.
Now if I use the increment or decrement
operator in front of a variable
then it's applied before any other
operators in this expression and
that includes the assignment operator.
So if we do ++poundsOfFlour,
then our total pounds is now
five because the increment is applied
before assignment and we can check to
see the new value of pounds of flour
which is two after being incremented.
Now if instead I move the increment or
decrement operator after the variable it
modifies, then it's applied after
the other operators in this expression.
And that again includes assignment.
So in this case we've put the increment
operator after pounds of flour.
And our total pounds is still
the original four pounds, but
we can see that pounds of flour
has been incremented to two,
it just happened after
the assignment of total pounds.
So you want to be extra careful
when you use these increment and
decrement operators
because of this nuance.
So I'd encourage you
to take some time and
play around with them in a playground
until you feel really comfortable.